on this episode of pop culture decoded
daily we explain why we think Chernobyl
on the Emmy for Best Cinematography we
breakdown why the new rainbow won't be
able to live up to the original and did
you notice any easter eggs in the new
birds of prey poster
[Music]
hi welcome to pop culture decoded daily
we are producers and filmmakers here at
insider and we're gonna break apart some
of the movies introduced series that you
guys love so each episode Nate and I are
going to take a look at a clip that's
relevant in the news that's been
trending people have been talking about
and get into what each of us really
loved about that piece and some of the
technical aspects that went into it that
you might not have noticed at first
sounds good so what are we talking about
this week so the clip that I brought in
today is from Chernobyl Chernobyl
nominated for 19 Emmy Awards already won
a couple Emmy Awards in the creative
arts Emmys which happens this past
weekend those are for the more technical
side of the Emmys and one for
cinematography which is what I want to
talk about so which episode we'll be
talking about specifically so we are
talking about the second episode of the
series and it's at the very end of the
episode the reactors already exploded
three men are going into the reactor to
go turn on a valve to prevent another
explosion from happening and they're
exposing themselves to a bunch of
radiation essentially a suicide mission
so let's take a look
usually with cinematography people think
of often like Lawrence of Arabia like
big bright beautiful landscapes and one
of the reasons I brought it in is
because you don't really think of
darkness as cinematography
cinematographers have a lot of jobs but
one of their main jobs and most
important is lighting a scene filming
for dark scenes is very difficult you
need to balance it between it being too
bright and too dark where you can't see
anything yeah exactly so for example
right here when his light is going out
and as you can see this is the only
light that should be illuminating the
scene but in the background here there's
some lighting and again up here with the
top of the pipe there right so that's
one of the important considerations that
cinematographers need to take into
account is how much lighting do I need
to put in where it's realistic but also
enough lighting where I can see so I can
actually show some of the behind the
scenes photos here's what the set looks
like as you can see here there are two
big overhead lights with diffusers on
them to make the entire scene a little
bit brighter there's always gonna be
easier to make a scene darker in
post-production then to lighten it back
up so you know something that is
reminding me a lot of is a game of
thones
yeah there was that huge controversy
about people saying I can't see anything
especially that battle Winterfell
episode where it was just pitch darkness
no one had any idea what was going on
but you know this not to throw shade but
this seems to be a great example that
shows like you can still convey darkness
without actually being dark and still
being able to see things yeah absolutely
and I do think they were at a bit of a
disadvantage with a bit more action E
right but it was pretty good right I
mean they're they're sort of explanation
was that they're trying to use the
lighting from that era which was like
candles and fire but I don't know I just
anything lush bathing yeah honey what
clique do you want to talk about today
right so as you know ramble last blood
it's coming to theaters a lot of people
aren't interested I think starting to
dislike you personally I'm a big fan of
the original so I gotta talk about it so
I I don't really want to talk about the
technical aspect of it I want to talk
more about the film itself as you know
it is is such a classic is like a
legendary status movie so you don't like
sort of why is that so here's here's
sort of what I want to talk about Rambo
is is you know if you've seen the first
one it was a very message driven movie
yeah right it was it was about
essentially it was about PTSD yeah it
was like it showed Rambo is sort of like
this really hurt hero who was still a
hero but he was very hurt from like the
war and the memories of like genocide
and everything like that
and all of a sudden you know what's
what's the first image that comes to
your mind when I say Rambo it is the
mass killing right where he's like has a
huge machine gun he's fun he's like I
think most people yeah but that's you
know that's actually not sort of the
image from Rambo one that's actually
like more Rambo - that's I you know it's
it is really weird cuz Rambo one is such
a classic and was you know loved by
critics so much because it had such a
clear message and showing a story that
we've never seen before of like a PTSD
so it carried on that and many people
think sort of that message disappeared
by the second one but that's not true
you know if you watch the second one
there's still a lot of that like lines
about the nihilistic side war and all
like we're all products of the
government and things like that and then
by third just action is gone yeah you
know I think it's also also it changed
how action was portrayed because first
one you see it Rambo is really really
tactical he's always hiding and then
from the you know second and third one
he's invincible which yeah I think it's
mainly because it changed that
message you know it changed from sort of
focusing on the PTSD and the damages of
war to like yeah action hero like let's
list most people down I think it's very
ironic that there's someone who sort of
represented like the dark side of
Governor and how we're sending these
people tours and not really taking care
of them and after a couple movies become
like an American hero and he's like you
know the quintessential symbolism of
like that era like America like strong
America we got to go to other countries
and like protect our interests kind of a
thing which I always found really
interesting and ironic at the same time
so our team here at insider can't wait
for the new birds of prey trailer to
come out be an official one yeah but in
the meantime they dropped a poster the
other day and we just wanted to point
out a couple Easter eggs that we were
pretty excited about there at least an
extremely high resolution poster and you
we were looking yes they knew that down
here that we were looking for the Easter
eggs so if you look here Harley Quinn
she has crossed out the references to
puddin which is her pet name for the
Joker
obviously Jared Leto's Joker seems like
it probably won't be appearing so
there's that and then another one that
we found was on you and McGregor's
character he plays the black mask and
but as you can see here he has a RS very
tiny RS on his on his left over there
and that's a reference to his character
Roman sionis who then turns into the
black mask later well that's it for this
episode of pop culture decoded daily we
will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]